hey guys what's up this is andrew for
transitions.com so in this video guys i
want to show you what can happen on
tesla in the coming days coming weeks we
have some interesting information so i
want to share that with you and i want
to show you how this is related to what
is happening on the rest of the market
let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so tesla chart daily time
frame i want to do something very quick
with you here in this video i want to
show you how to quickly analyze the
price action of a stock and arrive with
some solid supports and
resistance so bam i'm removing
everything it's going to be very quick
so you always start
from horizontal lines and you connect
you check the highs and you try to
connect highs lows consolidations all
right this is the first step so here i'm
seeing high i'm seeing a low okay i'm
i'm at the bottom of the gap up
uh so this is a good trend line so i'm
gonna keep this one here then second one
here but this one is
a bit useless for now we are far from
that
then here okay low low low right so it's
pretty obvious for now but as you can
see we miss some of them because there
is just too much space between here and
here right 60 is too much we want to
have more information so here i see hi
and here is your consolidation okay and
then this is the little game that you
need to be a bit used to here it's an
area right you can see i have some code
consolidation here so i can be on the
top of the consideration
i can be at the bottom of the
consideration and match this high and
this gap down almost this high and i can
be even lower
here
okay because i'm at this high this high
so i can be basically in this range all
right so i i don't want to keep two of
them
because i can be even lower as well i
could put one here because i much this
high so i have a whole range here of
support okay i can keep it like that
actually
okay
then
we i need one more in this area so i
just put it randomly and then as you can
see as i move it to see what is fitting
the best and here i have one high
okay
i like this one all right because i have
one low one low
one high here match this whole
consideration i don't know if you guys
see well
but you can see i'm matching very well
everything that is happening here the
most recent past is the most important
remember that days okay so here
i i really like what i'm having here
guys okay i'm gonna keep it like that
and i'm having enough information then
once you've done that you need to find
the what is the trend to find what is
the trend you need trend lines all right
so we go for trend lines and we try to
find a trendline that is fitting well so
guys not complicated you just take the
lows and you all right and you try to
make something that is
fitting well i like this one
because i'm matching well here here i
have one two three four five
six seven eight
nine ten reactions all right guys so
this is a good trend line
unfortunately it's broken i heard in my
last video that this strong land was not
correct so please explain to me why it's
not correct to me it's very correct and
as you can see i did my last video
around here and i told you that we would
probably get rejected around this level
and we did guys all right because
present control after this breakout so
you can see we have a breakout we have
the volume increase i can watch it on
the weekly time frame it's cleaner guys
it's even more obvious you can see guys
you can add some electrodes counting if
you want from here but first you need to
do your trend lines it's more important
okay so once you're here as you can see
bezel and control since uh that breakout
and right now this blue trend line is a
resistance line as long as we are below
that bears and control and it's not good
to buy especially not high you can buy
low i'm going to show you the levels but
buying high is very very dangerous in
this situation when i say buying high it
means uh buy on the breakout okay so you
can do some trends here fan breakouts
but guys you're going to get trapped so
careful i'm going to show you what i
will be doing here but first yeah bears
in control uh as long as we are below
that level then last thing you do guys
you use moving averages
so i'm coming back on a daily timeframe
because the daily timeframe moving
averages are more used by traders so
they are better to use weekly moving
averages are not very used you know and
here we can see two things very
interesting so the 200-day moving
average that was acting as support for
the past two years guys
has been broken uh retested
and we are just hovering around that
level so it's showing that there is a
fight between booze and bears right this
is the information you get from the
200-day moving average and the 20-day
moving average guys as you can see for
the past two months the 20-day moving
average is giving you the momentum guys
all right so it's a very good
information about who is in control you
are below that there's in control you're
above that booze and control as simple
as that all right so we're just going to
check the information that it's given us
by this 20-day moving average and as you
can see we are rejected once twice three
four five six seven eight nine ten times
guys all right so bears are just using
that to sell so be careful and here like
i said don't buy on the way up whenever
you are in this kind of situation
because as you guys can see here bam
this is a bull trap okay guys avoid that
and once again i'm explaining all of
that in my course if you're interested
in the description of this video and
here i want to show you if you don't buy
high so buying breakout is very high
then you buy low so where are you gonna
buy when you buy low you are gonna buy
at the support levels but buying low is
a risky game because the price action is
dropping so you usually need to average
down your levels you have two different
strategies either you buy high with a
stop loss or you buy low without stop
loss averaging down and if you're
interested to know more about that i'm
having my first uh live webinar uh next
week guys uh the link is the description
of the video as well so subscribe to
that commercial you guys support me
there uh it's gonna be very interesting
i'm gonna show you the different
strategies you can have whenever you
have a swing trading portfolio okay you
can buy high or buy low and the strategy
is different the risk management is
different the profits you can expect are
different i'm doing that for flow banks
i'm invited there there as a speaker
guys uh just quickly for the story i
have some family that is working at flow
bank and they invited me to do that i'm
still of course independent but i'm a
speaker for them for this webinar
so once again guys please come there and
it's gonna be very interesting so just
subscribe and do not miss it it's gonna
be live one hour me talking you asking
questions and you're gonna learn a lot
of interesting things all right and here
for tesla as i'm saying if we buy low
gas we just buy at the support level so
what i'm gonna do personally i don't
wanna buy at a support level that has
already been tested once because it's
weaker guys so i will personally if we
drop and i'm gonna show you how to know
if we're gonna drop a knot i mean not
for sure but some good indicators if we
come back here guys i'm afraid we're
just gonna drop and here i'm gonna start
to buy 6 25
and 540 right this is my buying area
right by
here this is what i'm gonna do okay guys
so this is my view once again not
financial advice guys but this is a very
good area to buy and if i miss it
because you're going to tell me yeah but
if you buy too low you're going to miss
tesla trade first i've already made
money on tesla so if i miss it i'm still
happy that i already took some profits
uh on the way up and second thing more
important of course guys i'm gonna be
able to catch it later why because here
i'm gonna try to buy low and if it's not
working then i'm gonna buy high but
using a real trend line right not those
trend lines that are in the bearish area
i'm going to wait first for bulls to
take back control to come back above the
900 level and then we're probably gonna
have here a battle and a consolidation
guys once again i'm explaining that in
my course very well and it's exactly the
same thing i did guys here and you were
here with me on discord look we have
exactly the situation the price action
we are here guys all right
we are here i think so i think we have
more downside if you miss this buying
level uh that basically as you can see
happen on the recent laws as usual then
you're gonna have this opportunity
consolidation okay on low volume then
volume increase breakout
and it's gonna be the same thing around
the 1000 mark so if i miss dubai low
strategy i'm not gonna miss the buy high
strategy guys i'm gonna be here uh to as
well let you know whenever it happens
but we have time for that yes as you can
see the bush momentum is broken we have
time for that
so i'm bullish on tesla of course on the
long run but on the short and medium
term guys i'm realistic and i know that
uh this the war between russia and
ukraine guys it's creating a massive
rally in uh the commodity prices look at
nikhil yeah it's too
150 in a matter of few days all right so
that's a very strong move up aluminium
as well you guys know that tesla is
building cars and they need those
materials that are coming from russia so
as long as the war is gonna last those
prices will keep going higher traders
will keep speculating on that and
inflation probably won't be transitory
we had the inflation figure uh yesterday
guys 7.99
the market is saying it's not too bad
guys seriously john paul is telling us
for a couple of months almost years that
the inflation will be transitory guys we
can see that it's not i mean for now
it's not it's gonna last and especially
if this war is gonna last longer i don't
see any solution for this conflict to
stop right now because i mean i don't
see how to satisfy both parties uh putin
and zelensky because they both want
something that cannot happen at the same
time so i think that unfortunately trans
uh inflation will not be transitory but
once again i'm not the one that is gonna
decide about that there is the fed
meeting next week guys in five days and
this is going to be very important
basically as you guys probably have
understood uh the war is impacting both
the growth and the inflation and if the
growth is lower we're going to need to
keep rates low but if the inflation is
higher we need to increase it quicker so
the fed is in this situation where they
need to try to forecast what impact is
going to be bigger and we're going to
have the decision next week so i think
that until that day we're going to be
sideways waiting here and when the
decision is going to come if jerome paul
tells us that the inflation is going to
last longer than expected and that they
want to i don't know maybe be a bit more
hawkish to prepare for that it's going
to be a very bad signal sent to the
market it's going to
especially not be good for tesla that
that is meeting this commodity prices to
sell its cars so this is what is gonna
probably uh be the key information that
we are all waiting for and once this
information arrives we're gonna see how
the market reacts but for now it's
impossible to say so i think a sideways
move until next week is what is making
the most sense and then uh something uh
big is gonna happen either we're gonna
rally but then get rejected and then
we're gonna be able to get this uh
consolidation and breakout that will
happen here uh or we're gonna drop more
and then i think that buying between 550
and 630
is a very nice opportunity so that's it
for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to show i'll see you guys